I didn't feel up there I was great it
was awesome it was too fast it was too
fast you could have you could kept going
I mean that's when we wait all day to do
is play and so you know dig arena full
of people it's fun I wish we could have
played a whole show awesome you guys
have another album coming out a third
album coming up how different is it from
the last two I would say it's pretty
different in some ways and also not
different in other ways it sounds like
us every every song we write and perform
and record ends up sounding like us
because it is us yeah that's just our
chemistry so what is the tone what are
you singing about this time I guess cuz
each album you know makes I mean we've
had some sad songs before I think but
this one has a few more this time but
you know then there's also the fun like
dance grooves so where do you guys get
the inspiration for some of the sad
songs or some of the good times that is
it from mostly your own lives or do you
grab it from inspiration from friends or
from family yeah I think it's a little
bit of both you know when you're writing
songs you know obviously have to draw
from your own personal experiences but
your radar is always up - anytime you
talk to somebody who's going through
something or or things like that you
know you sort of put that in your memory
bank and you draw from that when you're
right - so mm-hmm do you guys like
touring more or do you like being in the
studio
I had to pick I'd say like reading some
and where's the best place to write your
song she liked writing on the bus or
just if something comes to you or just
wherever you wrote the good one
interesting on this album the first two
songs that we wrote for the album we
wrote in the studio which I've never
done before but make it sweet and
there's a song called here you know
while you were going through the process
well we booked a studio date and had no
songs in mind we just said let's try to
write one from scratch and record it
that day and see if we can pull that off
see what happens and that's what came
out so that was interesting
Wow and that's not something that you've
done before no we've never had that that
opportunity before everything has been
made so fast yeah we wanted to take a
little bit more time with this one so
that was the way we started the whole
thing off was with let's just see no
pressure if we don't write something
that's okay we've got time to make a
record but let's just see what happens
and you're on the cover of this album
right I was that because fans said we
want to see your beautiful faces no your
parents said we want to see you sometime
I mean we did we did decide like maybe
we should be on the cover you know we
can see the benefits our label obviously
has always been like Cash's can we
please put you on the cover and we're
like go that's something silly over
there but this one the album cover
itself we just loved so much because it
was such a spontaneous thing it looks
like a set but that was a real it was a
real dressing room behind the stage and
we were all sitting on this goofy couch
and we snapped a picture that
that's amazing all right and there's a
big announcement too right
yes we are starting our we are all the
Minotaur okay that's amazing
that's fantastic why'd you pick Canada
and now just flatter us like why did you
yeah it's pretty amazing America's not
cold enough in February let's get colder
well if you need a stylist I know where
we can get great jackets great tooks and
everything that you're gonna need okay
you just call me and I'll fix you right
up
awesome okay I'm in it's a hot well
we'll definitely see you on tour awesome
you are nominated for a CMA yes that's
incredible what does that feel like does
it add pressure or is it just a great
honor oh yeah it's just a great there's
no pressure we we you know at the only
time that there is pressure is right
when they're reading off like they're
getting ready to give the award then we
all I clam up a little bit but for the
most part you know it's an honor to be
included just in the conversation and
we're having we're winning every night
you know we have fans and people listen
to our music so that's the real takeaway
for us but so will you prepare a speech
or are you just gonna fly like typically
don't prepare we like the weird things
[Laughter]
okay nice all right well good
congratulations thank you thank you